[Musique]
c'est sur le site logistique des
maraudes du val d'oise
grâce à des volontaires du service
civique
nous sommes capables de préparer sans
quasiment d'erreurs toute la logistique
des marottes ce qui est absolument
indispensable
est ce si cette fois par semaine alors
notre activité elle est impactée dans
vous voyez bien la préparation la
précaution la prévention pour nous
permettre de continuer à aider ceux qui
ont besoin de nous les
approvisionnements continue normalement
par contre pour les gens que nous
rencontrons la vie est devenue très
compliquée certains ont disparu du
paysage parce qu'ils n'osent plus venir
d'autres que nous ne connaissions pas
sont apparues alors mon rôle est de
préparer les camions pour qu'il parte en
maraude à chaque soir donc j'assure la
préparation du chocolat chaud du café
ainsi que les plats chauds qui nous sont
livrées par sodexo
ensuite je prépare le camion donc je
m'assure qu'il y ait bien de l'eau du
lait tous les produits d'hygiène
nécessaires
les vêtements de problèmes ces sites et
si besoin ce qu'on fait c'est que en
tout premier on prépare donc le café et
le chocolat les plages on les fait
chauffer dans le four puis pour qu'il
reste chaud on les met dans des
questions posées comme ça aujourd'hui à
des gobelets c'est un peu plus spécial
puis à dérape de l'est en plus et pour
respecter les distances de sécurité on
leur donne directement le gobelet et on
les sert par exemple je peux vous
montrer c'est du boulgour et du poisson
du cola à cette heure là bas je vérifie
souvent avec les maraudeurs que tout a
bien été mise en place dans le camion
donc vous voyez dans le camion ce qui se
passe c'est que chaque chose à sa place
c'est à dire que ici nous avons tout ce
qui est grand protection sacs poubelles
etc
dans ce bateau là puisqu'on va sortir
nous avons tout ce qui est vert en
dessous couvert sucre ensuite ici ainsi
que ici nous avons tout ce qui est
produits d'hygiène ici c'est au cas où
il rencontre des personnes
supplémentaires qui peuvent leur donner
des petits gâteaux des combats des
yaourts en plus nous avons aussi pour
les animaux des croquettes l'eau le lait
est ensuite dans les glacières vous
pouvez le voir
c'est des petits sachets individuels
avec devant un 9 des compotes bientôt
couvert et boissons et avec ceux ci sont
en plus chaque semaine un colis avec des
conserves que les maraudeurs lors de nos
silos
on est parti
sur pau centre ville le vieux village
trois personnes
un couple and i'm soldes
et ensuite
le connaissent de toute personne à les
voir tourner là bas après ça ira
la gare de mm
vers l'avenir à la mairie de coussins
ville
on finira par fausse
qu'on est leur seule et unique taxe de
un but qui a plus personne dans les rues
devant les garages
ils n'ont plus la petite pièce qui va
bien le petit sandwich qui va bien on se
paye un café ils ont vraiment plus rien
ils sont seuls et si nous on n'y va pas
il ya personne en fait ils sont vraiment
ils ont faim il ya vraiment plus rien
par exemple on leur apporte aussi des
attestations vierge parce que mine de
rien ils seront arrêtés mais les gars
ils peuvent pas imprimer une attestation
père y avait des femmes qui se
retrouvent
la rue une femme avec enfants à la russe
elle est en danger elle est vraiment
d'une part il ya aucune hygiène
les enfants
enfants dans la rue sous son aile
compliqué même devant un abribus même
devant
il ya des gens malveillants et elle peut
se faire agresser à peu se faire violer
après il ya beaucoup de chantage aussi
on voit parfois des femmes cedef du
chantage
pour un abri pour que ses enfants
mais à quel prix qu'en est il à l'école
les enfants qu'ils soient
vis-à-vis d'un repas tous les jours
une demi heure
du bassin
ok tu peu près
ok super
plus de toujours la glycine elle était
super job mais l'argent est une zone
même si j'ai pris un an tu veux du lait
qu'on a préparé sa rentrée parler des
colis en place et les colis strike on a
stocké dans les glacières comme sait les
personnes qui sont qui sont abrités qui
dit hacker alors amis des animaux
peuvent utiliser
oui on va regarder avec eux s'ils ont
besoin d'eau d'hygiène et julien ça va
se terminer
on en a besoin par contre sur le
confinement ça aurait été encore mieux
respecter s'il a écrit tous les jours
regardez les amis ouais merci
là on arrive à l'hôpital de gonesse
nouvel habitat en fait à les rejoindre
le pc sécurité où il ya des gens qui
sont qui sont à l abri pour la nuit
donc là environ 6 m dos dames que la
d'habitude on descendait à plusieurs en
bas et l'a vu qu'il ya des mesures à hp
t il ya plus que deux maraudeurs qui
descendent pour aller voir les
bénéficiaires et nous on va les attendre
à l'extérieur et on va pas s'approcher
des gens
moi j'ai déjà vu quatorze femmes
ils ne font
et comme je disais dans les enfants à
des enfants qui sont relativement jeunes
et nouveaux nés et le plus jeune elle
n'avait pas une semaine on là ils
étaient couverts
il me rappelle on avait vu le tordu
couverture de survie quand tu vois ça
pas très bien pour ça mais n'est-ce pas
de l'est pas de bouche rien vraiment
rien
nous repartons n'était pas spécialement
chez afin d'en bas
des enfants jusque là
là c'était dur à entendre mais
heureusement tu es obligé de te mettre
une barrière et jack et voilà ce qu'ont
fait ces pierres de bonnes
c'est pas normal de faire ça tout le
monde le report avait récemment
écoutons le fait en lui c'est bien ça
ait des gens mais il faut ce qu'il faut
se protéger
tu peux pas en arriver là du coup à la
gare de villiers le bel non là on va se
mettre à l'abri votre tv
six siècles à venir
voir et en plus la boulangerie c'est
c'est un programme ainsi
boulanger nous donne du pain et ce qui
est bien avec les cieux c'est que même
si les plots n'a pu nous en fait à
il y a
je pense gardeur il assimile un chariot
la règle numéro 1 s'est jamais tout seul
toujours à deux même si on va un petit
peu plus loin chercher un bénéficiaire
que sur un banc qui est caché quelque
part et qu'on sait qu'il est là on y va
à deux et on signale à l'autre équipe je
vais là je reviens dans 5 minutes mais
jamais tout seul parce que ben une
situation peut dégénérer très rapidement
et que même un bénéficiaire qui ne
connaît bien qui nous reconnaît en cas
d'ébriété
ça peut malheureusement dégénéré il peut
ne pas nous reconnaître il peut vomir sa
colère sur nous et puis nous en vouloir
voilà donc jamais tout seul jamais
on y va alors on cherche ali ali c'est
une personne qu'on veut de plus
maintenant je prends deux ans et qui en
fait dort dans sa voiture sur ce parking
est actuellement il nous rejoint la gare
de villiers le bel
sur des points de rassemblement mais
avec le confinement on essaye de en fait
allé voir les gens directement là où ils
sont pour éviter au feu de bois tous les
regroupements
c'est un petit peu des enquêtes on va
dire et des fois on n'a aucune idée de
pau où ils peuvent être et du coup c'est
dans ces moments là on tourne et limbe a
par exemple on était déjà passé dans ce
cas devant ce parking est bien de
retourner de 20
alors ça c'est un collectif des restos
du coeur dans lequel il ya une boîte
tarde pas une salade froide
des petites des petits gâteaux secs à
grignoter
il ya une compote et une boîte de pâté
d'accord voilà ça c'est un colis de ce
qu'on appelle un colis et c'est
absolument inconditionnel est-ce qu'il y
en a qui veulent des attestations pour
circuler merci du fallacieux revient à
vous la fais rien
ton corps et c'est le fait d'être
impuissant devant une situation qui soit
quand je vois tu voir apparaître
une tranche une table rappelle à
l'ancien hôpital de gonesse quand elle
est partie vers 2h 2h du matin que ces
deux gamins un appel
vu comment tu peux laisser une dame dans
la rue à deux heures du mat avec deux
gosses 1 dans une poussette et est même
parfois on se sent minable quoi
parce que tu te dis ce qu'on fait c'est
rien c'est vraiment rien parfois même on
se dit je vais arrêter parce que ce
qu'on fait ça sert à rien
on a dû filer à bouffer ce soir au quai
mais demain matin quand elle va se
réveiller elle aura de quoi faire
nourrir ses enfants
elle aura quoi lui donner une couche
propre à son bébé donc ça sert à rien ce
qu'on fait c'est juste un tout petit
pansement de crottes sur sur une plaie
qui n'en finit pas quoi ouais mais je
pense à s'avance alors
mais voilà c'est déjà ça
je crois sincèrement que c'est leur pays
c'est
d'une manière générale c'est de voir les
enfants
se précipite sur une
faire qui est pas toujours très bonne
le gamin quand comment
le bol
vraiment il a faim
voir une femme avec ses potes
possible
pas dans nos têtes
et c'est vrai que parfois on en veut à
la terre entière
tes envies tir mais bordel qu'est ce
qu'on fait voir
association qu'est ce que
autorités pour ça mais il ya plein de
choses qui existent jusqu'à qui sont
débordés
il n'y a plus de place nulle part c'est
saturé saturé
et partout
23h donc là on va aller à la fausse info
service être
dans un camping car
jeu même si même si
même si des hommes et ne sont pas
pouvoir pourra pas rencontrer
au moins s'assurer que moi qui ai lac ça
se passe bien
si on a la chance de pouvoir
un café il passé
petit cadeau avec ou sans aller jusque
là avant toi alors fait le monde ça fait
plusieurs fois qu'on peut pas se voir et
il ya chaque wii de dormir donc là on va
d accrocher un sandwich un colis par an
sur son rétroviseur un design aura il
aura de quoi manger le mans et en plus
ça marquera notre passage on sait vers
la queue on est passé d'un y en aura
peut-être une marque et un truc là
dessus
on en a fini à la tournée on va
retourner au dépôt de taverny on va on
va arranger le
matériels n'ont pas d'équipé
et puis après vingt autres
[Musique]
tout nettoyer fort chargé le camion en
colis en quantité suffisante pour que
l'équipe de demain puissent partir à une
fois que tout ça sera fini qu'on va
retrouver une vie normale on va dire ne
pas oublier que la solidarité s'est pas
seulement là une affaire d'un mois ou
deux c'est tout le temps c'est toute
l'année et qu' il suffit pas d'être
bénévole on peut faire de la solidarité
avec son voisin de palier avec sa
grand-mère avec le mec qui habite en bas
de chez nous avec n'importe qui comme un
p'tit sourire un p'tit petit moment
partagé un petit café un petit truc ça
coûte rien et puis c'est toujours
valable
et puis c'est apprendre aussi à nos
enfants que voilà ça se transmet et qu'
[Musique]
il n'y a pas besoin d'être bénévole dans
une association
quelque chose de bien quand il suffit
juste d'être bienveillant tous les jours